so just watch for yourself
the mainstream media appealing appearing
to fail to press dr anthony fauci on a
new big report bombshell report that
says the wuhan laboratory in china
actually did use u.s money to fund
controversial research where scientists
manipulate viruses often making them
more transmissible
dr fauci has gone on the record in the
past insisting the united states did not
fund that type of research
yesterday a cnn anchor sat down with
fouchy for nearly 10 minutes after the
report was released
did not even ask him once about it
instead they talked about whether large
crowds should be allowed inside football
stadiums this fall
when you look at crowds like that you
approve of that or is that just not
smart
no i don't think it's smart i think when
you're dealing particularly in if you
know outdoors is always better than
indoors but even when you have such a
congregate setting of people close
together first you should be vaccinated
and when you do have congregate settings
particularly indoors you should be
wearing a mask
now i'm a girl who loves some fruit low
hanging or otherwise apparently lots of
low-hanging fruit there because oh just
ask about this picture
just ask about this picture here's what
i can't get over also is that the
journalists the media that's supposed to
represent ordinary americans i keep
coming back to that today who is
representing all of the questions that
americans have who is going to hold that
man accountable for his statements and
the fact that policy flows from this
authority that he has essentially
granted himself that affects every
american and meanwhile to those stadiums
look i love a good football game you
know it and look at the u.s open it was
packed i didn't hear him talking about
that exactly and that should be a local
decision so for example my home stadium
the huskies the best team in the world
they have
there you all you have to do you show
your vaccination card or you show a
proof of a negative test right masks are
a different story it's a different issue
at this moment but there the whole point
is that they set what's best for them
and they set a way to have those fans
enjoy the civic life that we are all a
part of in the social life and the
culture and community without
ostracizing them coming from this one
man who continues to be given a pass on
fundamental issues including the
origination of this virus and what this
administration what he knew about it so
i always believe that comeuppance you
know southern word
uh it gets you in the end so it's coming
why lie about this why not just say what
the truth is and say you know i don't
know fog of war i'm sure they can come
up with something um but you know be
honest about it china's not going to let
us look at their records now if there
are any to even see anymore if they
haven't destroyed everything no and he
can't be truthful because the truth
would mean that very likely if this did
originate in the lab u.s taxpayer
dollars helped to fund a pandemic that
was unleashed upon the world out of a
lab in wuhan china what is so galling to
me is when you read these 900 pages of
documents that were obtained by the
intercept the grant request actually
acknowledges the dangers of this
research so dr falchi i presume he read
the application for the grant which said
this the grant proposal acknowledges
some of these dangers fieldwork involves
the highest risk of exposure to sars or
other kovids while working in caves with
high bat density overhead and potential
fecal dust to be inhaled so presumably
he read this and presumably he
greenlighted the funding and now lying
about it to congress but senator rand
paul has been on this from the beginning
i hope he continues you know um
vivek i look at this also
slightly different way
was it just a lie
or was it
people are too busy they're not smart
enough to figure this out i will say
it this way and make it really really
simple we didn't pay for the pandemic
yeah well look i think that it is really
important to see with clear eyes what
the likely source of this pandemic was
all right the u.s had a ban on gain of
function research rogue scientists
disagreed with that decision anthony
fauci is on the record disagreeing with
that decision decides through the back
door to use private parties to fund it
abroad including in china and then
either by accident or worse that leaked
from a lab and created the pandemic of a
century and you wonder why americans
mistrust science or scientific elites
they have given you no reason to trust
anything that they say the resp possible
responsible parties in part for the
origin of a global pandemic the greatest
pandemic of a century going about lying
about it for the course of the last year
now say wear masks and wear vaccines
have given the public no reason to
actually trust them and to me i'm
speaking as a whatever i studied
molecular biology at harvard i care
about the pursuit of science i care
about the pursuit of truth i care about
public trust in science and we have a
crisis of public trust in science but
the reason why isn't because ordinary
people are too stupid to know that they
should trust science it is because the
scientific elites in this country
including dr anthony fauci has given the
public absolutely no reason to trust
them at all just allow me kennedy i want
to double down something on something
with vivik you know as i've been talking
with nurses and doctors 40 of whom in
the city where we are now in new york
city reportedly 30 to 40 percent now
maybe the numbers changing a bit are not
vaccinated and it's for some of the
reasons why you're talking that they
don't trust the science-based medical
industry that they live in because they
have seen so many different things look
i've lived in elite america including
among scientific elites and nothing
annoys me more right now than the scorn
for the people who are skeptical of
getting the vaccine or the scorn for the
people who are skeptical of the advice
that they get without looking in the
mirror and asking themselves what role
they played in fueling that crisis of
institutional mistrust and i think they
ought to look in the mirror first for
deciding where that originated that's
really interesting and by the way you've
given us a way to get at it then we we
can talk about it if they don't trust
scientists which is what you're saying
maybe you're right
maybe we better take a look at why that
is kennedy yeah you don't have to follow
the science here you can you can follow
the money in the paper trail as uh as
vivik laid out and there is a lot of
accountability
still to be met by francis collins and
anthony fauci because they had a big
hand in this and they were the ones who
were able to give the up or down vote
almost single handed they end behind
closed doors
to these research grants and they were
the ones who changed the structure so it
would be easier to get that money out of
the country and to institutions that
were doing gain of function research now
the idea that the science is settled
that is very anti-science in fact there
were a lot of researchers who didn't
like the idea of publishing gain of
function research to begin with because
they thought it was a blueprint for
bioterrorism
that was being published so when all of
this emerged and scientists from the
wuhan lab started dying i'm sure that
doctors collins and fauci
had a very audible gulp because they
knew that the genie was out of the
bottle and instead of trying to figure
out how to keep the other genies back in
they're busy being scolds and finger
wagging and people who are going to
college football games who after a year
and a half they can do their own
cost-benefit analysis and make their own
decisions as to whether or not they're
comfortable being outdoors with a group
of people real quickly kaylee you know
this is not about whether or not
we can prevent this in the future as
much as it is how do we get out of this
right now
and what vivic has given us as a way to
talk about this it's not that people
necessarily don't trust science but if
it's the human beings that are peddling
the information which is supposed to
motivate or or dictate our movement
that's what they don't well that's
incredibly powerful information it is
and people are opposed to authoritarian
dictates so someone who's hesitant about
the vaccine if you oppose an
authoritarian dictate like you must show
a card to eat at a restaurant you're
going to have the opposite of the
intended effect so what do you do
what do you do you start allowing people
freedom put forward the science the
information about the vaccine we've all
had a discussion about it i had the
vaccine i believe in the science behind
it give people the choice show people
the science but don't oppose orwellian
mandates because that just backfires i
think that's what we're seeing it's
interesting vivik you're brilliant i did
not know vivek was like all up in that
in ivy league microbiology prior life
yeah
well it's good for this one i went on
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now